[Music]
william what we're back i know that yeah
i love that song a monastery
all through the night we should do
something right maybe a uh a modern
version of that with some snare and a
kick drum or something well you want to
have something you want to ask a dj to
do that a remix who would we get someone
who likes the show do a funky remix of
that in there who's that producer he's
very good isn't he uh fat boy slim nope
hey haters heaven what mm-hmm it's one
of his songs oh god yeah um what was uh
who is it um he did uh it did all of uh
amy winehouses
john ranson yes um ronson ronson not
john ronson i think he's a journalist
yeah yeah ronson hmm hey i think this is
a new edition swords i like that just in
case you and i have a disagreement we
can thwack each other i think that needs
to be doubled that's quite sharp is it
also you and i were lucky enough to
recently go to a convention where we met
some fantastic people over the weekend
and someone uh gave us a little furry
onion so whoever what wonderful person
gave us a fairy on then they're now
featured on the podcast thank you for
that gift we loved it we love seeing all
you guys this weekend i haven't held but
notice you've got one glove on dom yes
i've went for the singular uh driving
glove um
look which i think is a good look i i i
i do wear a driving glove every so often
when i'm driving because of alan
partridge because i love alan partridge
and he likes his driving gloves so it's
a tribute to him
but um i had them on and then when i
finished driving i thought well they
actually go really well with my t-shirt
so i'll keep them on and i thought you'd
appreciate it too do you wear two yeah
you're driving yeah but just one when
you're walking yeah just one as a kind
of like i don't know i think um
would it be fair to say that the hip hop
crowd is a big fan of uh
a singular driving glove really glob a
glove got a glove a glove i didn't know
that i think well
michael jackson might have been a fan of
the singular yeah he liked a single
glove and a few other people which we
won't mention and i've noticed yours is
tight tight well i've been working out
my wrists as you know bills have you and
i can barely button this now
and uh looks good you you were telling
me over the last couple of weeks so that
you're considering turning into one of
the world's strongest men
i was thinking about it because uh i
think it's good to give yourself some
sort of focus in life
and i started going back to the gym
since coverts got less
prominent and things like gyms are open
again i'm enjoying going to the gym yeah
and i've got to see that i've got this
trainer you see who i used to have in
scotland now he's got an app
and uh i go on this app now and he gives
me a workout and i think i like that
better than even you know getting a
trainer or anything oh really i put on
my headphones
it tells me exactly what i need to do
when you do it and i do it well good for
you so i was thinking about having a
word with him and i say look
i want to become one of the strongest
men in the world yeah how do i go about
that and then he'll just fill up the app
with what i need to do fill up that with
that and then your diet has got to be on
point oh what you've got to be eating
tons of calories tons thousands tens of
thousands of calories i want you to get
so big you know those strut like the
strong men uh routine
where they pick up a massive cannonball
yeah and then they run for like 30 feet
on top of a barrel i want you to do that
i want to do all of that i want to be
pulling articulated lorries pulling a uh
a plane with your teeth
oh i don't i don't know how to work on
my teeth we've just got to get really
strong gums i can tell you about that
i've got really strong gums
yeah but since you um started going back
to the gym i've noticed that you've got
a certain kind of joadave about you i
feel as if yeah i feel as if my my legs
feel good you know my knee i've been
wanting on my knee and my buttocks yeah
i think that's where they could get
that's where it began
and uh i'm enjoying it i'll i like to
you know squat
i'll enjoy a lunge
and an overhead shove good for you i
wonder what the french word is for
schmadev
peeling the onion
anyway we should do um a little bit of
housekeeping
you broke the
our microwave so clean and true
tell me some housekeeping i like how i
like how the song's housekeeping has
gone into complete anarchy it was you it
was you come up with that
but yeah let me go on
what have we
one of the things there's anyone written
in nick from wisconsin oh wisconsin whis
cons i don't know where wisconsin is to
you
so i won't even bother giving you the
hand but only if you know
no i don't
just someone will tell us at some point
yeah nick from wisconsin has uh written
in in regards to the uh swearing in lord
of the rings if you'd like to send us in
more uh suggestions since the uh
loatherings trilogy is a pg-13 you can
have one swear word
nick said in the extended editions when
gandalf confronts sarah mann in the
beginning of the turn the king after the
after the two plus the ants defeat his
followers instead of saruman saying
instead of saying sarah man your stuff
is broken
he could say saruman your staff is
[ __ ]
and then his staff falls apart and he
gets killed quite good
and then he gets killed i think how he
ended it there i like that it's quite
good in the books in the in the uh
return the king lord rings books sarah
man doesn't get killed in the same way
that he gets killed in
uh the films because we
oust him from the shire he's part of the
scouring of the shire this go ring of
the show if only we had the chance give
us a question dumb jokes he says do you
think that mary and pippin could have
gotten as far as frodo and sam did if
they being mary and pippin always big on
uh brackets this guy yeah yeah uh were
to take the one ring to mordor and again
another bracket including dealing with
smeagol shelob etc you could have just
used a comma it's a lot of brackets
there isn't there i like the brackets do
you yeah um
so could photos i think
the the reason why frodo gets as far as
he does with the ring and then how sam
really helps him out i think
specifically is due to the fact that
they are hobbits and they don't get
as affected by the ring as other
creatures would so i think mary and
pippin would do quite well there's
there's kind of an inkling in certainly
in the books
that frodo has a little bit of elven
kind of influence in his genealogy would
that be the right
family tree really
some some
elven ways
and that maybe he's the perfect
candidate for that but i still think
that mary and pippen would do a good job
i think we did brilliant and i think
we'd get it there faster and i think
there would be more laughs
and uh yeah i'd say it would be better i
think we'd be better and also i think
we'd find things on the way like you
know a tree
that um that grows oranges or something
and also mushrooms would find a lot of
mushrooms oh a lot of mushrooms so that
would make it more interesting wouldn't
it you could cook them as well the
closer you get to mordor because the
ground gets hot we can just cook them
just cook them on hang you know and i
think you know we get some laughs out of
smeagol and stuff yeah i think we'd be a
great kind of triple act i think we get
it done easy lovely question there jake
here
well done uh well we'll do this last one
here nicole from philly
in pennsylvania is that or philadelphia
philly well philly in philadelphia isn't
it so what's pa pa
yeah she said i'm a huge proponent for
all things animation from the beautiful
oscar-winning pixar films to the student
short films i found on youtube i love it
all considering your interview with
michael jacquino i would like to ask
what are your favorite animated movies
and or tv shows that you would recommend
personally my favorite show of all time
is
avatar the last bender last airbender i
got excited there i stu stammed it's one
of my favorite shows too
and one of my favorite movies is
spider-man into the spider-verse well
i love animated films and my dad calls
them cartoons do you know the difference
between cartoons and animated features
do you know what i don't i'll tell you
right now i keep telling my dad but he
still keeps going
but dad's a big fan of dismissing those
things yeah
cartoons are supposed to be less than
three minutes long really that's what
defines a cartoon whereas an animated
feature as we know can be a few hours
long if it wants to be
less than three minutes as a cartoon as
a cartoon so tom and jerry type vibes is
a cartoon because it's kind of a little
bit of a some of them are more than
three minutes some of them but initially
when they started out i think you know
because i think what cartoons did
initially on the tv is they were the gap
in between a show so you'd have a show
then the three-minute ad break and you
put a cartoon in there instead and then
another show looking in your eyes just
now you'll look as if you're not 100
sure it's three minutes
three and a half could be three and a
half minutes
um all right well my favorite animated
things well
standout ones for me i love the red
turtle nicole if you've not seen the red
turtle
uh it's kind of
animated in the style of the tintin
comics yeah uh drawn that way kind of a
traditional style it's not a completely
silent film because every so often our
hero does shout and make noises but for
the most part no words it's the story of
a man marooned on an island has a
relationship with the turtle stunning
beautiful fantastic i love spider-man
into the spider-verse last airbender for
sure i really like uh sword art online
which is a japanese thing i like
castlevania
inside out one of my favorite animated
films pixar coco so good
remember me
hello oh sorry we were just talking
about you know the what's the one where
uh the day of the dead
coco yeah coco yeah and he's great
once you once there's no more pictures
of you less than earth that's yeah i've
al well not always but i've i've thought
about that i've thought that for a long
time which is things are only truly dead
when you forget about them yeah you know
so that's it there's a beautiful message
in there that obviously you and i went
see up and i was i was pretty you were
in tears crushed i've never seen you
like that i was i was probably the most
emotional that i've been in a uh
in an animated they're brilliant but
here's the thing yeah to get slightly
controversial i haven't seen it yet so i
don't know why i'm commenting on it
but
uh like yeah
um
you were you had sorry feelings yeah i'm
worried dom because i love the toy story
movies and they've set up that buzz
is a toy who thinks he's a spaceman and
then in this movie he has a spaceman
yes he's not a toy at all yes how can
that be yeah it's caused derision i
think
mark kermode who is britain's kind of
most famous film reviewer he wasn't a
fan either and he said the thing that
they're asking you to do is completely
separate both of those worlds so the
buzz lightyear that thinks he's a
spaceman has no idea that there actually
was a spaceman that existed and vice
versa and i think that's kind of broken
the pixar model in a way a little bit a
little bit yeah because if there really
was a buzz lightyear that they then made
a toy of is this what they're saying
yeah kind of
well certainly in toy story that's what
they're saying right well and toy story
i just i never thought there was
actually a buzz light yeah right because
i never thought there was actually you
know he wasn't going against these
villains and galaxies and stuff so i
i'll go and see i'll i'll hold my tongue
down we'll listen i've got a question
from nicole
was what animated films do you like and
what would you recommend not what ones
do you hate and you want to spit venom
about tell us the ones that you love i
love i love pixels
and i used to love um
[Music]
saturday morning cartoons
i don't know if there were less than
three minutes maybe
there was a programme on
in scotland called
glenn michael's cavalcade oh
and glenn michael would sit and he would
put on cartoons
and i i used to say i'll use all of that
down oh yeah i could when i was a kid
did you ever watch battle of the planets
yes yeah i used to like that what about
kids in space with like weapons and
stuff love that what about the thing
what about the one what was that hold on
not the hair pair bunch no it was like
oh
they were like
soft toys but guys inside costumes and
teletubbies kind of like teletubbies but
they played cartoons and some of the
cartoons they played banana splits yes
yeah
um there was one that i
felt the arabian knights oh i don't know
that one that was on the thing that was
a cartoon i loved it dom that was my
favorite i've just remembered and there
was a guy in it he could turn into any
animal and he'd do it like this size of
an elephant
fun size of an ant
but it's all the size of a black bird
what was its size uh well he wouldn't
just don't it turned anyone back so he
would turn into any animal of any size
or could he like could he go ears of a
wolf no noise of an ego he's the size of
a monkey and then he turned into a
monkey and they wouldn't
specify he wouldn't say wha wha what do
you want a spider monkey yeah yeah
an orangutan not a monkey is that an ape
yeah a chimpanzee
not a monkey is that an ape
carry on
fresh from san diego california comes
the only sunglasses brand i'm ever going
to wear again blenders eyewear and
you're going to be just as hooked as me
when you see these awesome shades they
are fantastic i've got a fantastic black
pair and you can't see
they're really nice just try them out
yeah you do look fantastic chase fisher
started blenders by selling his beachy
shades out of a backpack while doubling
as a surf instructor on pacific beach
very cool his goal was to create an
adventurous mid-priced eyewear option
with the same cool factor as other
leading styles unlike expensive big
brand shades that you've probably lost
or smashed in the past just like billy's
done 300 times blenders are actually
affordable so you're not going to cry as
much when the inevitable happens
blender's team of in-house designers are
constantly coming out with new styles
from orange polarized wrap-arounds
tortoise shell frames with purple lenses
to classic gold arms on a black lens and
it's not just sunglasses blenders have
prescription glasses readers and blue
light as well as snow collections with
goggles and accessories live life in
forward motion with blenders today to
score 15 off your blender's purchase
visit blenderseyeware.com and enter
promo code onion vip that's
blenderseyewear.com code onion vip for
50 off blenders rocked with pride
worldwide
ren is a startup that's making it easy
for everyone to make a meaningful
difference in the climate crisis right
now they're focused on monthly
subscriptions where you can calculate
your carbon footprint then offset it by
supporting awesome climate projects that
plant trees protect rainforests and
remove co2 from the sky their goal is to
unlock the collective actions of
millions of individuals to drive the
systemic change needed to end the
climate crisis i know a lot of people
have been looking for a way to offset
your carbon footprint with the climate
crisis being as bad as it is just now i
know i have and dom has as well and
we're always trying to do our bit but
the great thing about ren is they make
this easy you can pay monthly they will
plant trees offset your carbon footprint
i think it's a really fantastic service
it's a nice feeling isn't it to think
that you're contributing something that
maybe we'll plant trees for future
generations you know 30 40 50 years down
the line exactly and they make it easy
they you know when you're trying to work
out how am i going to do this ren you go
on to their website you put in a few
figures what you're doing and they make
it easy for you round is a website where
you can calculate your personal carbon
footprint based on your lifestyle then
offset it by funding projects that plant
trees protect rainforest sequester co2
and more signing up for ren is an easy
way to do something meaningful about the
climate crisis wren practices hyper
transparency once you sign up to make a
monthly contribution to offset your
carbon footprint you'll receive monthly
updates about the tree planting
rainforest protection and carbon removal
projects you're funding you can even see
the exact coordinates of the trees that
you've planted it's going to take all of
us to end the climate crisis do your
part today by signing up for ren go to
ren dot co forward slash onion sign up
and they'll plant 10 extra trees in your
name that's w-r-e-n-dot
c-o-slash onion start making a
difference thank you ren
there was one that i loved when i was a
kid i watched it on my own i was always
trying to get my brother to watch it
with me but he wasn't interested and it
was the story of the musketeers
but uh the animals were all dogs so it
was dog tanyan
and the
hounds i remember that that was really
cute i love that show probably hasn't
aged very well i think it was quite
dated and the animation style's quite
dead but i would uh say the word
charming about that yeah i remember that
i used to have a friend when i was
younger as well who took up cycling
in
scotland didn't see him for
for uh months and months and then he
came back
and everybody called him the musketeer
and i didn't know why because he'd been
outside so much they said he was the
dart tanyan
okay yeah got a suntan you mean yeah um
i love that
well is that it is oh we've got a few
voicemails should we fire in a few
voicemails yeah give us give us a voice
we don't have johnny clues with us uh
this week we have shanti and i'm
expecting that um maybe the studio is
going to be wonderfully run this week
hello mr boyd and mr monaghan my name is
lexi i'm a music therapist from
nashville tennessee
i wanted to first say thank you for
having a music therapist on your podcast
a while back getting the word out about
music therapy
now i have some misheard lyrics from
pantera's cemetery gates
it's supposed to be reverend at the
beginning but all i hear is
red rum
red rum is this some conspiracy
and also i was wondering if you guys
could try to hit those high notes at the
very end when phil enselmo saying
gates
thanks guys
i don't know that song lexi lexie i
don't know that song either but you guys
obviously got a lovely tone of your
voice yeah it was lovely that red from
red rum which is murder backwards isn't
it red rum uh from the shining
red rub remember he goes
ram and you're like why is he interested
in the horse that won the grand national
no it's murder backwards
i like this heads lyrics
thanks lexi thanks lexi we'll have a
listen to that song and see if we can
hit it we can get one more
we'll listen to it and see if we can hit
it right hey dom and billy this is dr
steve from tampa florida love you guys
here's a riddle for you oh i stay in the
corner
and yet i travel around the world what
am i
i stay in the corner
and yet i travel around the world
i was gonna say a shadow but that
doesn't make any sense because is it
something they do with the moon
the moon travels around the world
shanty knows this one because she's
she's got her hand up and she's nodding
i know it wait a minute dom's got it
dom's got it i stay in the corner corner
i think i know it so i'm going to see if
i can help you get it right this makes
sense to me what's something that you
what's something that you put in a
corner a dance
yeah good but the other things that's
not a living thing a light
yeah i stand up late
a stand
you put it in the corner of something
it's like a it's a device that helps
something go around the world he's
totally got it i've got it out now it
helps what if what if you want to send
something around the world what would
you put in the corner i stamp a stamp
it's right in me
that's a great that's a very simple but
cool riddle thank you doctor yeah i love
that that's great um
well we have a fantastic guest but i
just thought just
just before we finished that because we
didn't really answer lexi's question no
and she said i wonder if you could hit
that high note at the end of that song
yeah should we should we see how high we
can make our voice go and how low yeah
what's the highest you can falsetto's
okay right right but we're allowed folks
here oh yeah good things
oh i think i can go higher right hold on
[Applause]
was that one what's that
but hopefully you're not wearing any
earphones people listening at home we
both nailed it that was good what about
the lowest right military effects my
mate keeps going like that
brilliant
hey that's worth subscribing to the
podcast for right right
alone a very low note and a very high
note you're welcome well we've got a
we've got a fantastic guest today should
we bring him on or should we talk about
him let's bring him on and then we'll
talk about it right to his face oh i
love that
william what it's not just you and i in
a room now we've been joined by our
wonderful guest
guy
you have no foundation to know whether
i'm wonderful or not right now you guys
are you boys are each going to have to
make this decision for yourselves over
the course of this period of time we're
going to find out in the next 40 to 42
minutes or so or if it turns into 30
minutes you can guarantee that you're
not a good yeah we just understand maybe
things just don't vibe you know bills do
you want to read a blurb yeah go on then
i'll do the first part right all right
lovely i want to get your second name
correct branham branham branham i got it
right
guy branham is the creator and host of
true tv's talk show the game show yes
that's off the air that's been cancelled
this is an old bio and i apologize
bills bad start
do you want to do your bio
yeah okay do your bio i'm sorry no
listen my name is guy i'm a stand-up
comedian i write for tv shows sometimes
i had a really funny talk show called
talk show the game show it's available
on hbo max if you want to go back and
watch it it was cancelled it was
canceled so it wasn't that great yes um
i am uh one of the co-stars and a
co-producer on
uh bros which is a romantic comedy with
billy eichner that's coming out this
fall
uh and i'm also on a show called
platonic on apple plus i don't know when
that's coming out okay good well you've
clearly done your own research well this
is much better than johnny clues gave us
yeah he gives up a bio from like months
ago look this is my failure ultimately
that i haven't written a nice new
updated bio it's fine i also got a
goddamn book that it'll come up later we
know about the birth yes it's called my
life as a goddess why don't why don't we
write your bio right now well there's
some more blurb here guys stop me if we
get this right guys also appeared on at
midnight yes chris hardwick the nightly
show with larry wilmore the meltdown
road to roast and debate wars as a tv
writer guy spent three years writing for
hulu's the mindy project was a producer
during the shows last season other tv uh
writing credits include a league of
their own from amazon punk'd
and awkward on mtv another period on
comedy central billy on the street
fashion police on e that means he's
watched the grammys at joan rivers house
whoa we can need to talk about john
rivers but also you're on punk they
tried to punk me didn't work oh really i
wonder if it was like the season i
worked on it was like a late season and
all we were doing was mean stuff to the
cars of people who were in twilight
movies 100 that was just all we were
doing that was the hot movie hurting the
cars of people who had been in twilight
movies okay and it was really it was not
the job for me okay
you don't like being mean to people i
just think i think
like
i think that pranks are crimes that like
young heterosexual white boys do to each
other and then it's like this is okay
they're not threatening where i think
women and gay guys prefer to just say
mean things about their friends
behind their back and that to me like
fashion police sure like is
i'm far more comfortable with that than
like
hey let's make this person think their
daughter died oh yeah that's definitely
not cool i like a prank but i like a
well-meaning prank
i'm not big on you you don't like pranks
you don't like practical jokes really do
you no i like a prank that at some point
during the prank the person who's being
pranked feels like they are in some way
involved in the prank as opposed to
everything that's kind of gunning for
them here's what i'll say about pranks
like when i had so my talk show the
whole point of it was that you scored
points by doing the sort of things
you're supposed to do on talk shows like
plugging a project like i just did when
i mentioned my now to funk talk show but
the thing you scored the most points for
was telling a story about an onset prank
because i respect that you guys as
actors have to be pulling [ __ ] in
you know each other's trailers during
the course of things yeah like otherwise
how do we know we're making a movie yeah
i don't think on onset pranks happen as
much as people think in the same way
that people assume that actors walk away
with pieces of the set all the time
which is really not true yeah because
they need that they need to
pick up some stuff people ask me all the
time so what what did you take what did
you steal from the lord the ringset and
i was like i didn't steal anything from
the lord instead you'd be fired
no absolutely giving stuff but that's
that's the beautiful thing about being
on a television program that has been
cancelled it's at that point in time
it's just open season to steal anything
you can oh yeah and so i really you know
like and respect that but you guys like
the the process of making those films
over like all it did you make the first
two together did you make all three of
them
oh um yes i was just listening to
oh uh gollum what's his name 96. andy
circus talking about like his first
scene was like on the slopes of mount
doom and it's like that's it's
ridiculous to think about you guys
having to keep track of that yeah but
truly like that they're having to keep
track of all of that haters for that
entire period of time terrifying yeah
crazy yes um well what about your book
my life as a goddess i mean it's a solid
book i think it's funny i think it's
interesting
it's about me um it's like
it's in between a memoir and me sort of
like talking about and analyzing pop
culture like i generally take pieces of
pop culture that like meant something to
me at a part of time in my life and then
sort of like analyze that while
analyzing my own life but it comes up
today because there are two recipes in
the book and one of them i made for you
today oh yes a peach cobbler which we're
gonna get into yes
the conqueror teamed up with warner
brothers consumer products and designed
five iconic virtual challenges to take
everyone from the enchanting bag end to
the unknown depths of more law
the conqueror virtual challenges was
created in 2016 to help solve one of the
biggest problems that many people face
in their lives starting and sticking to
regular exercise to enhance and maintain
health and well-being and it's working
so far the conqueror has helped over
400 000 people globally
who says sports and fantasies don't have
a lot in common let me tell you how it
works bills you scan the qr code and
download the conqueror challenges app
join the first challenge using the
unique code and don't stop until you
reach mordor follow the same path as the
fellowship and go through the five
trails in the same order the shire the
fellowship mines of mori the eye of
sauron mordor walk run cycle or do any
activity to advance on the middle earth
map enjoy stories and postcards every
time you reach a milestone get five
beautifully crafted medals for each
challenge completed and help the one
ring travel from mesmerizing hobbiton to
dreadful mount doom
there is an awesome feature that allows
you to go through challenges and
fellowship dumb did you know that no
tell me more oh yes you want to rack up
mileage is faster now it's easier than
ever through the fellowship feature
grab the helm and create a fellowship
that will keep you accountable and help
you through your middle earth journey
the number of members in your fellowship
is unlimited so gather as many as you
want i would say probably nine is good
though and then that's a fantastic
number
where can listeners go to find it bills
simple dom the app can be found at the
conqueror dot event slash onion that's t
h e c o n q u e r o r dot event slash o
n i o n the conqueror dot event slash
onion
when billy and i were doing press for
lord of the rings for three years
running when we came to la
they put us in what was then the wyndham
bellage but it's now the london hotel
yes and in the first year
neither billion or i had a car so we
would just walk around sunset plaza
having lunch and stuff and at one point
we walked down san vicente and had
breakfast and lunch and we were like man
people are really friendly around here
everyone's asking us what we're up to
what we're doing tonight where we're
going and then on the walk back i think
we then realized that we were in
the center of west hollywood which is
yes the gay district of los angeles
we're just being an adorable little
couple we we were embraced by that
culture and i absolutely loved it yeah i
love that
yeah i think that's great yeah it's a
wonderful thing i mean what a scarring
experience coming to los angeles and not
being able to drive like it's just it is
such a weird
like different experience to have like a
pedestrian life in los angeles it's my
number one tip to anyone that really has
never been to l.a and they're coming for
the first time what should i do where
should i stay blah blah blah i always
say you have to rent a car or hire a car
as we say in britain and they're like i
don't want to i'm on holiday and i'm
like that's fine but what that means is
you're gonna only be able to walk
somewhere and it is
38 degrees outside it's 110 degrees
outside so you're really going to
struggle you know so hiring a car is is
a big thing when you're in l.a were you
guys daunted by the prospect of having
to reverse all of your instincts for
driving
i'm just so scared of ever driving in
britain like
i would do it wrong like i would just
the switching to the other side of the
road i would end up killing several
people and myself you know what happens
though because you sit on the other side
of the the car yeah and then it all
makes sense yeah really
yeah yeah
do you remember that we cause billy's a
big fan of the seaside because he likes
to take his bucket and spade down there
i was i used to be driving with you very
often when we used to take that snaky
sunset right all the way down
get to the sea so i'm on the side of the
car that is closest to the curb and in
the early days of you doing that i'd be
like bill's you're way too close to the
game
yeah oh god i'm out i'd be like just
slightly get over to the white line
because i was all right though i was
just all right the curbs in california
are like three feet high you know in
england that you can hit them and just
kind of use him as a guide but you're
obviously going to buckle your wheel
here and you know when california is at
its best i mean the thing next to the
road is just you know a wall of stone
that would destroy you immediately so so
you can't drive a manual shift car a
stick shift card i don't know how i was
only talking about driving on the other
side of the street but thank you for
bringing up my lack of masculine acuity
yeah i am a failure yeah um yeah i i do
not know how to drive a manual shift car
most people from the united states don't
i always thought it was super easy you
just don't you feel like the car
actually talks to you bills dom is so
good at driving thank you that he wears
a driving glove he has a little driving
glove on even when he's just sitting on
a chair the the thing that happens here
is the left-hand side of my body always
wants to think that it's driving right
okay so that's where i keep that on and
then if i hold something like this it
thinks that it's just holding the side
of the the door do you know anyone that
wears driving gloves
um i mean not that i know of like i've
done potentially like a lady in a late
80s music video like yeah kind of thing
but not anyone who i go into dom's car
and he puts on gloves yeah it's a
tribute to who i believe is
the greatest comedian to have come out
of england since peter sellers who's a
guy called steve coogan yes famous for
alan partridge and you know a whole
bunch of other characters and
alan partridge is probably his kind of
greatest creation and alan whenever he's
driving is very strict on putting on
driving his uh driving gloves so it's a
little tribute to him i do i do love the
process of putting on a glove even
better taking off a glove oh lovely i
think they truly you can't take off a
glove without being a prussian field
marshal you know like you just want to
give orders um but i myself like i'm not
a driving guy i'm not an accessories guy
do you drive uh like i do drive i'm a
californian it is my obligation but like
at the point in time when my father
cause like i'm from a little farm town
in northern california and so like
driving a stick shift was something that
a person was supposed to learn um but by
that point in time my dad and i were
just frustrated enough with the basic
process of driving that we were like
well this doesn't need to happen
well let's take it way back since we
like to do on this show we always like
to have guests on that can potentially
inspire people to maybe don't go down
the path that you've been in your career
so
tell us
as a young man or a youngster
did you always want to be working in
comedy did you want to be a stand-up
comedian and how did that all happen i
mean i always wanted to but it isn't
particularly a practical way of life so
i
you know i wanted to do creative things
i liked creative things but uh i came
from a working-class family in a little
farm town and my mom was just like no
you need to be able to make money so
after i went to college i went to law
school and i
graduated and i came back to california
and i took the bar
and objection right um
i mean i'll sustain it it really would
have been fun wouldn't it i mean you
know the tv shows about it really make
it seem more exciting than it was in
practice did you find it were you across
the uh depp heard trial watch it i did
not pay that much attention to it like i
sort of knew what was going on i saw the
greatest hits
i didn't watch all of it either but some
of the language kind of seeped into the
way that i speak i love i'll allow it i
love that when someone's speaking and
you say something slightly controversial
i'll allow it sustained
no i mean it's a space full of drama
it's a space full of drama
um but then i
realized that that was a terrible way of
life and i didn't want to do that
terrible in terms of just way too much
work and too serious yeah it was like
everyone i was at law school with was
really
very willing to put in lots of time and
effort and i was like i'm going to let
things slip through the cracks because i
do not care about this enough uh and
then i came back to california and i
guess in that job you probably need to
care a little bit because people's the
rest of their lives could be on the line
absolutely like you can skaters real
easily and i came close to it several
times and i was like oh i don't want to
destroy my career this way i want to
destroy my career in a much more like
splashy and interesting way beautiful i
want there to be dead people involved
yeah i want to you know hurt america's
soul in some way before people are like
we're done with him
do you have a favorite courtroom uh
drama film
oh
uh yeah there are lots of good ones i
mean
there's one called adam's rib that no
one remembers i don't know
it's a it's a kathryn hepburn spencer
tracy movie where they're like okay so
get it it's the 1940s but she's a lady
and a lawyer and she's in a relationship
with another lawyer and they end up on
opposite sides of a uh politically
charged
like uh
like murder case where uh like a couple
is involved and they have to figure out
can men and women be equals
and you know it's the 40s so the answer
isn't really the one that you want right
um but it's real good okay adam's rib i
like devil's advocate it's a lovely uh
semi one also about the devil and then
the verdict the verdict is so good
yeah fantastic billy any uh courtroom
dramas jump out
is that a genre that you enjoy it's not
something i really think about tom does
that really famous one isn't her with
the jewelry was that eight angry men not
12 12 angry men eight well the other i
knew the restroom weren't that angry
yeah
so yeah the others were indifferent
i'm interested in stand up yes like
gives me the fear
how how did that come about
well like i just i like to stand up and
you just you just let you like it are
you heroes oh
one of them's about 200 feet that way
right now i got lost on my way here and
found sarah silverman oh yeah
hey it's sarah um
you know i like uh
margaret cho like
like
like um
oh
what's robert klein uh alan king like i
you know i just i looked up to
like chris rock all of these people look
good everybody shows you kind of like
different parts of
the art form that like are meaningful
but the thing about it is like
it require like you only have to believe
in yourself for like 30 seconds to be
able to write a joke or get a joke out
and i was like this is a good way for me
to start in sort of like creative stuff
because i only have to believe in myself
for very brief periods of time
and then the great part about stand up
is being mad at yourself afterwards for
how you feeders yeah and like that's how
your whole growth process works is just
being constantly depressed for four
years
i watched that sounds like a natural
build that'd be good
i was there quite a lot of clips of you
uh before this is it's really funny some
really funny stuff and like really
assured on stage so have you been doing
it for a long time yes i'm quite old so
wow
when did when was the first time you
went on stage yeah tell us about that
okay so the first time i went on stage
was just this uh little cafe in san
francisco
and i was so nervous that like i got on
stage like as quickly as possible said
the jokes that i had written right in
exactly the way that i had written them
and like my knee was bouncing the whole
time like i was not
i was so
terrified for for like
you know
months and months and then it really was
um there was this one uh venue in san
francisco that always got good audience
because robin williams would go there
two times a year and then just for the
rest of the year people showed up
because they knew that they might see
robin williams
and like there was a very attractive
couple in the audience and i envied them
and wanted to make fun of them and it
really was sort of like
it wasn't the first time i did stand up
but the first time i sort of like broke
free from what i was planning to do and
just did what was there in the moment
was like when
things really fell into place for me
and are you on the circuit now are you
doing a lot of it i mean
like the circuit kind of broke down for
two years you know like things changed i
have dates i should plug
dates you like that's why we're here um
uh
august 19th to 21st i will be in
lewiston maine main beautiful part of
the country and then there's another one
and i don't remember what it is okay
well go to maine and then maybe you can
tell them their way yes go to
guymoranum.com and look at my dates if
they're updated there
um
but i haven't been
getting into like a regular rhythm in
los angeles has been hard since things
have started opening up again you know
just like
that there is that way that you really
need to be doing it
two or three times a week and as there
are is there clubs in in los angeles
where you could just turn up and say oh
i've got a couple of minutes that i want
to try in my head that's how
stand-up works that you know i'll be in
my apartment and i write a couple of
gags and i think well i'm going to go to
the club now to try these out i mean
they're like
usually i follow the rules and like the
improv a week beforehand is like
what dates would you want to come and
that sort of thing but like going into
shows and just sort of
being pushy and saying hey let me on is
it always feels nice you know it always
feels nice or like especially in a
different city to just sort of like
randomly show up to a show and be like
hey
i'm kind of a big deal will you let me
on
have them be like of course
wonderful what about uh tips for a young
stand-up that's the is a fan of the
medium and wants to try what would you
say you just have to do it a bunch like
it is i am so impressed by the fact that
there are people who started stand up
during the pandemic who's like first
open mic
was on zoom do i think that they learned
anything from a zoom open mic no um but
i like you just have to do it so much
and you have to love it for its own sake
which i think is just something
across
like
many art forms
people are like how do i do this and
succeed and the thing is i feel like
do it because you love it and that's how
success happens and it doesn't really
make sense to people because people are
like how do i get a manager especially
here in los angeles people are the
people who start in los angeles are
exposed to success so early that's the
way that they think about things and the
thing is is like if you can
love this thing then under whatever
terms you're having to do it you're
going to be doing it well and having a
good time yeah yeah yeah come from a
place of wanting to just do it and then
the success will come from that william
i said i was watching something with an
artist the other day and he you know he
just started painting and he and he went
to you know some art gallery and said
you know would would you take any of
these or put them up and the woman says
okay what you should do is go and paint
400 paintings
and then come back and you'll have an
idea of you know what your style is
you have to just do things and do things
but this guy sadly had already done
about 800 pages and he said
he said well from from where you are now
go and do another 400. wow that's a lot
so it's just that's the thing isn't it
and i try to say this to my son as well
if you do something i remember as well
they found some early sort of bronte
sister stuff that was just awful
apparently because they did
15 years after that to make something
beautiful and you have to just do it and
do it and do it don't you
yeah and i also think like there's a
wonderful way with
like with stand-up you always want to
feel like this person is telling this
joke in the moment just to you but the
simple fact is is like
you have to go through this process of
telling the joke so many times that it
becomes lifeless to you that then you
tell the joke so many more times that
you like find stuff in it that nobody
else would it really is a lovely process
to like
get a piece of material
so hard and so strong that like it
really can deliver for you in any
situation where you are
finding the life in it and the thing
that you loved about it
every every time you're doing it it's
like do you have a favorite joke
oh yes
one of my favorite jokes is like one of
the first jokes that i ever wrote and i
will tell it to you now how can we do
you know that feeling right after sex
where the thing you want most on the
planet is to get as far away as as
humanly possible from the person you
just haters yeah that's the trouble with
masturbation
[Laughter]
lovely
good one yeah i like that it means a lot
to me
it's a personal joke um
yeah there's a great there's a great
story about going back to like time in
the water and just doing something over
and over again there's a great
documentary i was recommending it to you
at the the last convention mirror
about sinatra or as some people say
sinatra which is fine
uh
called all or nothing it's on netflix
it's great it's like a four-hour
documentary split right down the middle
early sinatra late sinatra
and at one point when he's become
established
and he's gone through his jazz period
and he's now kind of a staple and you
know beloved and all this kind of stuff
oscar nominated blah blah blah
they bring a young he's in a club with
all of his pals and they bring a young
kid in
like 17 18 year old kid sinatra's like
late 20s and they have this kid seeing a
sinatra standard and he sings it
perfectly and he all or nothing or
something like that and he goes over to
sinatra and says what do you think and
sinatra says that was fantastic
now go away
for like eight ten years and sing it all
around the country and then come back to
me go live a little live with the song a
little
and then it will take on board a little
bit more of the cadence of sinatra
that's kind of what you're saying with
the career right yeah and i think the
stand-up that i like
has
chunks of your soul in it and i think
that there are it is interesting seeing
people
who
have success very early and stand up
because i mean it's not like people have
tried to make reality shows like
american idol or
that sort of thing for stand-up and it
doesn't work in the same way because
it's not just like a four-year-old can
sing like a four-year-old doesn't know
how to be a stand-up comic you know um
but there it is interesting to see those
people who like
figure out the technical
part of things really early and are very
capable at that and then have to go on a
separate journey of
what is it that i want to say you know
what is it about this that makes this
joke mine
do you find quite often that
it's difficult for someone to have the
whole package you might have someone
who's extremely confident on stage but
their material isn't great or you might
have someone with great material but
their stage persona's not great and
finding that kind of chemistry is not is
not common i mean
the wonderful thing about it is like
it's it's such an individual thing that
everybody's combination is magical in
its own way the people who are good if
that makes any sense to you that like
um there's this woman named aparna
nanchola who is very possibly the best
joke writer in america and she has the
weirdest most different kind of stage
charisma like it really is something not
rooted in confidence but lack of
confidence but it is also hypnotic and
delightful to watch like you know it is
really cool that like everybody
gets to make their own product yeah and
have it exist on its own terms and it's
just
it's so lovely like
one of the things i miss most is the
regularity with which i was just getting
to see my friends do stand-up um and
like it is only my own fault for not
going out more yeah it is just i have
been seduced by the charms of my own
apartment yeah yeah no i get it and like
you said that
you're you guys are all in the same art
form
but the differences between
someone like sarah silverman who i've
seen a bunch of times i think is
fantastic the difference between her
version of stand up and let's say like
chappelle or eddie izzard is so
different yeah but they're all telling
jokes and they're all telling jokes in
their own way
have you seen eddie izad live oh yes
she's incredible yes well i'm probably
my favorite stand-up comedian of all
time i mean dressed to kill just like
destroys me like
such a sense of command as a performer
and
so smart so area
like and
i had a friend who was obsessed with her
like 10 years ago and she would work
stuff out at largo and he was always
making me go and it is interesting to
watch people
to watch a special as it's still being
figured out right right
so what about the the writer's room so
you've been in those right yes
how does that work
like
is there a script and then you guys
write gags to it or do you arrive
to a plain piece of paper well it's the
most it's the most fun thing on the
planet you guys like at its best when
you're doing it right
truly
dominic dazzled by the size of your
water bottle thank you very much not a
euphemism your commitment to hydration
is truly you've gone california right
here yeah well i'll tell you a very
quick story about this i was um i was
scuba diving with a with a group of
people that i didn't know and he just
took the sea weather i took the entire
pacific ocean with me i was scuba diving
the group of people that i didn't know
and a lady had this and i was kind of
taking the michael out of her for a
couple of days going man that is huge
that same things that you guys were
saying that's a hell of a commitment to
water and she said because it's so big
and so heavy and cumbersome you fly
through the water very quickly and i've
only just filled this up when i was
leaving but it is true you kind of want
to get down to 3pm as quickly as you can
just so that you can carry it so thank
you for that guy anyway
please continue um writer's rooms are
great so the thing is is you start out
in a writer's room and
like
your showrunner like definitely has like
a vision for what they want for the show
but use all sort of like
pitch
directions that things could go in and
every everything like that it was sort
of built more for the 22-episode world
that existed 10-15 years ago
more than now but then like usually
within like a week you start
going through and just breaking an
episode of television like figuring out
what the plot points are and then you as
a room
get it very very finalized as an outline
before one person goes off writes a
draft of it and then everyone comes back
and you spend just a shader's time
making it funnier punching it up doing
stuff like that and it was a couple of
years ago
i had an idea that i wanted to sell to
like britain i was like this is an idea
that is more appropriate to there and i
was like talking to people about it and
in the process i realized oh if
like if i do this
i don't get a writer's room like i
you know in britain you write six
episodes of television and you get like
one person to be like your script editor
or whatever
um and it's there are ways that like
america has become entranced by that
america likes this idea of
you know um
one person writing every episode of a
show and directing it and editing it and
stuff like that like with girls and
stuff like that but i am so proud of how
funny american television can be yeah
when you have this many heads
getting in and putting jokes into it and
the thing is now we we don't have as
many tv shows that are full of jokes as
we used to and personally um was
like terrified and floored by how funny
the later seasons of shit's creek
managed to be
and when they won all of the enemies i
was like dear god no
canada is doing this better than we are
should we go to war
yeah
i mean when i'm when i'm i think with
all countries
when they when they do it right it's
hilarious when when the united states is
funny it is incredible comedy i mean i
think i was saying to billy last weekend
i think larry sanders show is my
favorite tv show of all time i mean it's
just so good riptorn was so good he was
incredible and like julian garofalo
one of one of my great inspirations as a
stand-up uh early on but like i she's
brilliant
trifecta of shandling tambour and riptor
yes incredible um
but also as you were saying with
singular voices coming out of britain
like you know i think john cleese wrote
faulty towers with his then wife connie
booth but like ricky gervais's work with
stephen merchant officers
i just got done watching abfab uh like
the first three seasons of and it's like
crazy that that's
it's just 18 episodes but like every one
of them is a classic where like in the
old school american 22 episode style the
joke was always like episode 17 never
good
um right but it is
so much fun to work with a collection of
voices and learn the process of sort of
like
working together and really being able
to appreciate and enjoy and bounce off
of people like it really is the way that
like
comedians hanging out after a show you
just get into that rhythm of
everybody's on and nobody's in charge
and you know you're just having fun and
like writing in a writer's room at its
best really is that thing of
so like
we now mostly work over zoom
and i hate the way that punch-up happens
over zoom like so much of the time
they'll just send people off to write
their own jokes and that's [ __ ]
because people write the same joke
separately and you don't have that
moment of you said it this way i have to
make it better yeah and those moments of
like because
at its best it's like
the best kind of collegial competition
i'm just sort of like
i need to not embarrass myself in front
of these people i really respect and i
really want to make them laugh yeah i
love seeing those moments in like
sitcoms when a gag's not working and you
just see all the writers heads yeah kind
of oh they've tried that yeah no don't
try it again i think that's great and i
think we just like
we we got too comfortable with the
machine and we started doing like we
started using this well-honed process to
make crap
and it's it's different when it's sort
of a machine like that as opposed to
in britain where like oh
you know michaela cole's so funny let's
let her do something for six episodes
you know where this machine
did sort of
start churning out crap a lot of it yeah
yeah yeah well what for you are the uh
what are the standout benchmark american
comedies just to make sure that we've
seen them have you seen the dick van
dyke show
i don't think i have seen the dick van
dyke show oh the deacon tech show is
like an early family sitcom but the guy
he's a comedy writer he writes for a
variety show so you have
like it's from the era when everybody
still had vaudeville skills lying around
and it was like you know we are going to
make people sing we are going to make
people tap dance that kind of thing uh
mary tyler moore show our first classic
sassy gal in the city show
you know
uh
you're you're golden girls you're
designing women um
yeah like those are and and then you
start getting into the like voicier 90s
ones like the larry sanders show yeah
billy's not seeing it
never seen it it's it's an album i think
it's shanling's best work right i mean
but did you watch it's carrie shannon i
like it's the gary stanley show i mean
it's gary
you're right that you're right that
larry sanders is better but there are
ways that the sh like
the shaders of him throwing haters fall
yeah in uh its gay schandling show
and also the breaking of the fourth wall
is incredible the breaking of the fourth
wall was so good
and like
it was it was shaders that comes at a
time when sitcoms were all over the
place and the same thing everywhere
where like um
the larry sanders show stands on its own
yeah like it is still
uh good and it's in its own way ah [ __ ]
haters riptorn talking about liz
ashley's ass on that show i'm so glad
that we have that for posterity yeah you
know like and it's almost like i mean i
think it genuinely is my favorite tv
show of all time so i can go on and on
about it but that
that trifecta that you've got where they
they almost create a singular beast
those yeah you've got
channeling the host who's insecure about
the way he looks and his face and his
ass and is that girl gonna you go home
with him tonight and then you've got
tambour always insecure that he's gonna
get fired and then ripton trying to keep
the entire show together they become
this
this hugely insecure self-involved
paranoid
singular beast it's an amazing thing to
see well there is i get really mad at
how much la loves making shows about l.a
like i think we really have forgotten
how to make stuff that's about the rest
of america um but there is the way that
like everyone gets to sink their teeth
into it more when it is these sort of
people that they know and there is that
way did you watch the comeback
love the comeback right like i mean the
comeback is is just one of the
smartest most nuanced things sort of
like tearing about this world that like
lisa cujo has like been in yeah um and
like i
in the same way it's gary
the larry sanders show is just like
delicious because they know these people
and they hate these people and they are
these people and the ability
to like tear apart the person you almost
are
is the best yeah um i think shandling
was a big fan of that right he's a big
meditator he was big on transcendental
meditation i think he had done a lot of
work on his ego and was aware that this
business does a lot for your ego in a
bad way and i think with gary
shandling's show and larry sanders think
he's consistently wanting to like kill
his ego or at least compromise his ego i
do think a show that has your name in it
makes you go crazier like any anytime
you have a show and it's resting on your
shoulders you go a little crazy but and
there is that way that people come here
because they want to be that kind of
crazy
and it's why those shows are the best
because you can like
both romance the ridiculousness of these
egos but also tear them apart and push
yourself away from it hopefully yeah
billy and dom eat the world
should we eat the world bills i'm
starving every week on our show we uh
try any elements of the world and it's
not that common that someone actually
brings a home made
it seems fundamentally dangerous to me
you guys saying what's your favorite
food we're going to eat it because it
seems just like a setup for poisoning
well but also just sort of like for you
guys to hate something that somebody
else really loves
we're very very positive here and also i
think it started off that we were
thinking more along what's happening
today that people are really bringing
something
and we wanted it to be like from
people's childhood or or some sort of
memory or something so um i'm glad
you've made this something look i mean i
could have gone for a simpler direction
but it's tater's peach season right now
is this this isn't it
beach seasoning guys it is peach season
i was just in my hometown which my home
county produces more peaches than the
states of georgia and south carolina
combined that hometown uh it is yuba
city california
and there's also the prune capital of
the free world oh um everyone's very
regular there yes um it's a lot of stone
fruits um but i was like my mom had sent
me with a bunch of peaches it's a little
early in the season so they weren't the
most amazing
um is the peach your favorite stone
fruit the peach is my favorite stone
fruit willian
can i tell you my favorite gag okay oh i
was looking for your favorite stone
fruit but go on but it just made me
think of my favorite gag which only
works if you're scottish okay are you
ready yes when i was younger
i had a trumpet tree in my garden
but a man from the council came and
rooted to toot
what do you think
you can use that if you want i don't
know how you do that in an american
accent is a trumpet tree a real thing no
it should be
yes
that's
that's very good it's not a nice guy
charming it's a lovely gag i could never
get away with it well you would say
rooted rooted it out if you were like
that's it also just requires a level of
likability
that billy has access to that i do not
really yes you do yes do guys
it's not my brand it's i'm perfectly
fine with it it's not my brand brilliant
um god's sake what's your favorite stone
fruit my favorite stone fruit a mango
oh i've changed my mind mine's also a
mango you can change it to mine i was
going to say nectarine which is just
basically a hairless peach but uh i'm
going for a mango because that is my
favorite that's the most popular fruit
in the world the mango i mean mangoes
are so good incredible it disappoints me
though well
why it's too big i mean that's true
there are these stories about these
mangoes that come from india that are
amazing and that people are like picking
up at the santa monica airport and that
kind of thing and i'm like
would it be wrong to travel
internationally just to taste better
mangoes i have a mango tree plantation
in india
yes in bangalore india so just just a
little bit of trivia for you there you
are hey we're eating a cobbler i'm going
to get into the couple of things
cobblers the blurb
i think it probably is well i'll tell
you in this blurb bill
cobblers were never meant to be pretty
says this blurb emerging as a makeshift
version of the ever-popular pie recipe
that came from europe and the united
states in the 1800s this dessert was
cobbled together by the early american
settlers using fruit usually preserved
canned or dried and clumps of biscuit
dough before baking it over an open fire
so kind of one of those desserts that
you just you kind of throw a few things
together because you've not got
everything like a number
yeah like an eating mess or a crumble
well okay also just fundamentally like
making pie crust in england where the
world is air-conditioned you can make
pie crust anytime you like though as
we've seen on great british baking show
sometimes global warming they have a
rough time the thing is is my mom's
insistence is that if it's cool enough
for you to make pie crust your peaches
are shaders and truly in this warm late
summer time you can't be trying to like
get butter into it's flour or whatever
you just have to make a cobbler what
you'd need as a bring in the cobblers
you can come on in
come on in shantae
shantu is being very polite there
waiting but thank you shanti oh oh
cuddly i feel as if i need some cream
with this
oh we've not got any we've not got any
should it be served hot or cold guy it
should be served room temperature taken
from your grandmother's oven that she
like baked it last night and it's just
sort of sitting there should it be
served with ice cream yes did i bring
ice cream no would you say a vanilla ice
cream is the best of this vanilla i
would think so too guy would it be all
right to just talk us through how this
whole thing came about because we could
read the blurb well you've just made
this if you want the recipe it's in page
two of one of my book my life is a
goddess event it's whatever books are
sold
but it's i mean it's a very simple
it's not as simple as you think okay
it's slightly simple because you need to
take a good solid like a cast iron um
skillet or like a a nice
sort of like
crockery thing that is has some
heaviness to it put some butter in it
and let the butter get brown that's the
only thing that's hard
butter get brown and not
burn and then you just uh mix even
amounts of uh cream sugar and
self-rising flour or
flour that isn't self-rising and then
you put some baking soda and some salt
in it and you put that in and then you
put the peaches on top of it and then
you bake it until it's done guys
pink yeah i think that's a good reason
to swear that i would have said it was
peter's delightful you have you have
haters king nails yeah
smashed it guy
very kind of you boys um how often are
you cobbling together some peaches
i mean
i am a man of generous carriage i have
no business generous carriage uh eating
peach cobbler with regularity but um
once every peach season i owe it to the
peaches
this is my occasion for the year well
yeah it's absolutely the tip was tell us
the history of it well who me
no not you gay
go on there did you and your mother
often sit around peach season and say
mother
as would be you mother
let's cobble together some peaches so
look here's the story is that my mother
and my dad's mom hated each other oh and
wait hang on a second let me just make
sense that your mother
and your dad
your mom's mother-in-law yeah my mom's
mother-in-law
hated her uh they hated each other oh no
but
um
my mom tasted my grandma see like my
mom's mom had made peach cobbler a
different way and then my mom tasted
this approach to peach cobbler which is
you know controversial there are some
people who are essentially making
crumbles and they're calling it gobblers
and my mom was like this is a better
cobbler and so um my mom was very
devoted to it uh for peach purposes or
blackberry purposes did that forge
together a slightly closer relationship
between your mother and her
mother-in-law dear god no they always
hated each other the anti-semitism was
too strong on my grandmother
now has your grandmother moved on to the
other side yes oh i'm sorry to that guy
oh um i'll read a little blurb here more
stuff about the peach cobbler it's just
believed to have come together in the
same way as the first cobblers did fruit
dough and an open fire peach cobbler is
a traditional dish served in the deep
south usually a company
jesus dom usually accompanied by a scoop
of vanilla ice cream other versions of
the cobbler tart pie taut
pandaudy sonker grunt slump buckles
crisp custard bird's nest pudding crow's
nest pudding have elements in common
fruit bots of sugar and flour but the
recipe for a true cobbler remains nearly
the same
as the ones that the american settlers
use by the 1950s peach cobbler had
become an american staple and in an
effort to sell more canned peaches
georgia those figures declared april
13th national peach gobbler day
what if haters okay yeah sorry i
shouldn't be cursing you but you're
you're saying that where you come from
makes more peaches than anywhere
including the state of the state of
georgia and also but like making
national peach cobbler day in april is
you know relying on canned peaches
and not fresh peaches very
very frustrating that's a fine trash
i'll tell you what it is
that finished it dumb yeah it's peter's
fashion very sweet you guys before we go
i have to say something to you here's
this
my constant fear in between the years
1999 and 2003 was that i would die
before uh return of the king came out i
it meant so much to me
um i was so thrilled when those movies
came out and and still to this day
dazzled that as somebody who loved the
lord of the rings as much as i did
it was good enough that there was truly
nothing about it that i was like you
know
there's that fanboy instinct to be like
this is wrong or whatever but like truly
like
what an amazing thing
to have
been part of and contributed so much to
so so that means that pre the films
coming out you had what read the books
read the hobbit we were a big fan yes
okay um like it meant too much to me
when i was in junior high and it was
just
like fascinating to me would read
anything
possible to try to like it's just it's
such good world building that there
really is so much to like sink your
teeth into and
i do like
so condescending to other fandoms that
are like
you know
you know haters dothraki like they made
up dothraki like a corporation paid a
guy from berkeley to write dothraki like
an old man who knew
like 19 languages yeah like
built
like all of those languages yeah it's a
master word and then drew the maps yeah
before he even wrote a word
through the maps yeah i mean oh there
was one time i was in a history class
and
just
all those guys in over-educated guys in
trenches in world war one
scared haters letting their brains open
up and like all of the amazing art that
we got out of it
is truly dazzling well well that's true
i've never thought about that yeah yeah
they're being hemmed in and they think
if i can survive this war i'm gonna
write this thing yeah who's that wilfred
oh wilfred
yeah um so so specifically what brought
you to the books you're at school and a
friend said you should read these books
you'll like them okay i'm very old so
there were these things called record
books when i was little where you would
get like a little storybook oh yeah and
it had like a little record that would
read it to you and i had one of the
hobbit and i was just like this is
amazing and then i saw the ralph bakshi
movie
and
was like thrilled but also it's haters
oh because it's a ralph bakshi movie and
i was a child
um there's some great things about the
bakshi thing for me specifically
personally i think the black the black
riders in the ralph batchy thing are
scary and brilliant there's a few things
about the hobbits that are not
as great and dynamic but the black ride
is a terrific like it's it's goofy in a
70s way but also like how old were you
when you saw the the bakshi films for
the first time actually i was probably
nine or ten okay because i like some of
that stuff was just like
so real as to be like creepy and
insidious and i didn't like it i don't
like horror films that kind of thing um
but like
you know um then it was just
but
like the hobbit was the book that made
me be like will you have to buckle down
and get through this book this book is
very very long but you
like third grader fourth grade or
whatever i was are like going to get the
peter's book good for you um and then
you know um
then i
read the lord of the rings and then you
get into the esoteric gators then you
get into
you know it's an incredibly rewarding
reading experience right we recently
went to a convention this weekend and
some guy came over to me and said
can you sign this book and i said yeah
and i said you know i was just chatting
with him i said what's your favorite
chapter he said i have not read it yet
he said i love the films i've not read
the book yet and i said to him
it is a commitment the first hundred
maybe even 150 pages which very often
you can finish a book in 150 pages
you know you're still in the shire
you're at the party you do the fella
that you do the uh council of aeron but
i said it is one of the most rewarding
reading experiences that you have
because it's a work of a brilliant mind
you know and like he
it all held together everything had a
point everything had a purpose
everything was going somewhere and with
some of these things that
it's so it was so funny watching la
react
to the first the lord of the rings and
then to game of thrones and all of
these books that were written in sort of
like
um
you know in homage or just stealing from
tokyo that
aren't as strong that don't hold
together and then amazon made a very
expensive first season of a show about
it and it's like no one wants this like
um or even
game of thrones getting to the end and
being like well he didn't know where he
was going
i'm not saying anything i'm i'm keeping
quiet as well but we do have to we do
have to give your cobbler uh some uh
schools yeah we have to school he has to
score a homemade
um cake but i will do it yeah guy i'll
tell you something about billy he
doesn't like to upset people and he is
genuinely a very nice man so i'm going
to go out on a limb here and say that
these skulls are going to be high not
only because your cobbler was fantastic
but because billy doesn't like hurting
feelings but also i don't like
dishonesty dom that's all yes that's
that's and that's probably overrating
so
there could be a bad score well let's
see so the first category is flavor
slash taste all right you don't get to
score it because it's yours that's fair
sometimes the guests do get to score but
i don't think you should yeah you just
have to witness guy i do have to give
her a high t score it's high for taste
no question i mean it's it's a 9.2 wow
i'm gonna go a little lower than that
just to give me somewhere to go i'm
going to give it a 9. i like the flavor
because
along with that sweet
delicious thank you it's about as ripe
as a peach as it's going to get
aesthetics how does it look now this is
this is where it slightly falls down now
a cobbler's not supposed to be pretty is
it guy
oh it's cobbled together well exactly
like an old shoe on its own terms it can
be magnificent the one i made today was
not magnificent and it was not presented
to you in its proper form here's where
the shanty you should be ashamed of
yourself
no no
here's where the beauty of the combo
happens when you have immediately pulled
it from the oven and it is still sort of
like
crackling and popping and like moving a
little bit yeah that's where the action
is a little bit of ice cream on there
then i mean yes if i had really been
thinking if
i had thought about the scoring process
enough i would have come in with video
and really been able to back up the
beauty of my cobbler and i have to say
this cobbler itself was not my prettiest
and you know it came to us as like piles
of chaos yeah yeah yeah piles of chaos
yeah we can we can see the dish
um
expensive i mean it's it's nice it
almost looks like i can't wait to do it
yes hold on till i check it guy because
i i'm not going to be eating off of
anything
looks like the end of a shepherd's pie
in there
you can put a nice shepherd's pie in
there oh that's nice though yeah great
job right scores looks i'm gonna
i'm gonna be charitable because it's
homemade and what a beautiful thing i
don't need your charity dominic all
right in that case i'll be honest
instead and i'm gonna give it a 6.5 for
fair okay no we're seeing a
corner no that was on purpose are you
meant to do this no no okay
so yes the corners should be like crispy
and buttery and have had the brown
butter acted upon them um but this was a
mess i put too much in that dish i've
never made this in that dish before
well billy's [ __ ] eating with his
fingers now it's a good sign
i like the um i like to have a little
burnt onion yes yeah me too but chef is
glad slightly
so
if it was just that i was looking at guy
i was really looking at a six point
something but looking at this nice dish
with it burnt around the edges come on
let's get up there to an 8.4 oh now
she's like
nice high scores for this i told you
it's going to give you high scores dom
billy's favorite category how useful is
it usefulness oh that's a great question
because sometimes we'll get a sauce here
or some powdered something a rub yeah
some [ __ ] maybe some fruit from
somewhere how if you've got it in your
cupboard how useful is it yeah to pitch
pictures on what you can do with a
cobbler i'm going to say part of the
pride of a cobbler is that it's not
particularly useful it is a it is a it
is a tool for special occasions like you
essentially
it needs to
like be summertime
and also you need to have like
like this is not a dessert for after for
after a meal of any substance like right
because it's too heavy for that it's
like this is only
in like
this is only in like grammar situations
right but it should be consumed it's
very specific yeah i don't know how
useful it is it's kind of like a casual
dinner pals hanging out maybe a family
thing and someone's like oh do you want
to just make us a quick coverage for
something for them something have you
got any peaches and then you're coming
over this i mean look if you have canned
peaches at war
frozen peaches and everything else is
just already sitting there in your hands
yeah you've got it that's very quick and
easy yeah i like to think which is
probably not right and billy always
corrects me on this can you bring it to
a soccer game and hand it out at half
time to the team oh dear god no i don't
eat your camera i don't think travels
well okay here's what i'll say for
usefulness two other things i would say
it is a dense enough dessert that you
could smother a person with it if you
were in a situation that you need to
kill somebody ladyfingers aren't doing
that yeah um and then what what about
have you ever seen
a vanilla ice cream peach cobbler kind
of scoop combination you know like you
could do that you could combine those
two things oh what are you like like
you're in an ice cream parlor
center and you've got you've got you
you've got your chocolate and you've got
your
maraschino cherry and then they've got a
vanilla ice cream with with peach
cobbler swirl you could have that surely
um i don't care for that ratio i'm sorry
and
ben and jerry tried a peach cobbler uh
ice cream it was okay my hometown like
the independent ice cream store in my
hometown makes just a straight up peach
ice cream that is amazing okay why isn't
peach ice cream something like if i have
two responsibilities here it's one to
say bros is in theater september 30th
good go see um everywhere bro
but most importantly to say why is peach
ice cream not one of our go-to ice cream
flavors why do we have mint chocolate
chip everywhere but you can't get a
peach ice cream what's the name of your
local ice cream parlor it's called
brock's what's up brock's brock's well
done chase
have you ever had peach ice cream and on
the island i don't think i have i've had
a i've had a peach cobbler now and i can
tell you what i like it let's get back
to usefulness i don't think i would say
i would say it is wet and dense enough
that you could put out a small fire with
it yeah i would say that too you could
throw that on something that's burning
maybe a book well it was already banning
itself
william what you said you weren't going
to upset people sorry about that
usefulness sorry guy i'm gonna give it
well you you pitched it like this i'm
i'm gonna give it a four
yeah
but i'll tell you well that's high
scores for the cobbler it's high scores
for a cobbler
thank you for bringing it and it's
absolutely delicious thanks for bringing
that in guys great thank you boys for
enjoying it you're very skillful yeah
a man of many talents
we love having people on the show full
of positivity and full of passion and
who knows guy there might be someone out
there who either wants to be a stand-up
comedian successful writer or simply
wants to make a fantastic pitch cobbler
and you've inspired them you've inspired
both those people you gentlemen have
been inspiring me for years already so
thank you guys very sweet thank you so
much um you guys would run out of time
get in touch with us uh
rate review subscribe to our podcast you
can leave voice messages at speak pipe
forward slash the french bunion william
well done if you want to get
merchandises at the uh friendship
onionpodcast.com it's cool hi fantastic
you're absolutely charming i'm coming to
see you just stand up over here but not
in maine not in maine it's too far away
it's very far are you doing any
california la stand-up shows anytime
soon i'm doing a show tomorrow night in
silver lake but that's too far from your
home
though billy you can stay at mine
tonight
silverlake tomorrow sounds fantastic
we'll see you next week see you on the
friendship onion turtles
[Music]
with me and hold me tight all through
the night you're shining bright i'm your
boy's the baby you're my pearl